Talk about another perspective, in
terms of what the good guys have to do.
First of all, we have to worry
about what we call prevention.
Prevention really is keeping
the bad guys out of our systems.
The bad guys are the threat sources,
they're going to try
to attack our system.
If we can keep them out,
that is prevention.
Unfortunately, prevention
is not going to be 100%.
If that happens, we want to detect
the compromise as quickly as possible.
People talk about advanced persistent
threats, APTs that go undetected for
a long time.
That means we don't have good systems to
detect that kind of malicious activity.
Well, if we find out that they
have breached our systems or
compromised them,
then we have to respond to that.
So response comes next, and what do we
need to do as part of the response?
We need to recover from
whatever that has happened.
If data was corrupted, maybe we have
to restore it and things like that.
And then remediation basically has to be
that the same attack
should not happen again.
All these things is what good guys have
to do so there are really two parts.
Sort of, how do you do that?
How do you do detection?
How do you do remediation?
And what exactly needs to be done?
So mechanism is sort of the how part.
You want to have a flexible
set of mechanisms.
So policy is always what is the way in
which we're going to address something
and what's done is through
this whole spectrum.
Cyber security, again, you're not
going to be 100% secure ever but
that doesn't mean that we
leave the door wide open, so
that's what good guys have to do.